is being screened for a concussion -  Kalavati Gobert also on the floor Adams  just two games you said a couple of  baskets here in the first half tonight  off the up and down those open shots  Westbrook open for a moment what's fun  with you guys last night  Russell Westbrook get to the basket  right body fights over the screen by  anthony Adams deep knees let's work on  the run thread the needle to George in  this next three minutes 20 seconds Adams  screening 12 point we the Jabberwocky  will hold  [Applause]  [Music]  five six and twenty seven you see the  shooting numbers here the thunder  off the turnover with a chance to take  the lead at Westbrook let's big blue  [Applause]